[MUSIC PLAYING]
WESLEY CHUN: Hi, and welcome to
"Serverless Migration Station."
I'm Wesley from Google, joined
by my colleague, Martin,
to help you navigate the world
of migrating from one product
to another, usually
as it relates
to one of our serverless
compute platforms.
Today, Porter will show us the
optional migration from Cloud
Datastore to Cloud Firestore.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, really?
Another option on migration?
What's wrong with you people?
WESLEY CHUN: [LAUGHS]
I know, right?
To be fair, we
did let developers
know in the module
2 and 3 videos
that Python 2 App
Engine developers really
only need to move from
the original NDB Library
to Cloud NDB.
Doing so makes it easier to
port applications to Python 3
and also get them
on Cloud Datastore,
the standalone,
NoSQL solution that
grew out of the original
App Engine Datastore.
Since the Cloud NDB client
library works with Python 3 App
Engine, users would only further
migrate to Cloud Datastore
or Cloud Firestore
client libraries
if they had a really
good reason to do so.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, yeah.
I think I remember,
but can you remind me?
WESLEY CHUN: Sure, Martin.
Both the Cloud NDB and Cloud
Datastore client libraries
access Cloud Datastore,
the underlying database.
Cloud NDB was created
specifically for Python 2 App
Engine developers
as a migration tool,
while Python 3 and
non-App Engine users
are directed to Cloud
Datastore immediately.
So developers
should only migrate
from Cloud NDB to the Cloud
Datastore client library
if they already
had code using it,
meaning it's where you
want to consolidate
to using just one client
library to talk to Datastore.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Ah, that's right.
Thanks for the reminder.
But now what about today's
migration to Cloud Firestore?
WESLEY CHUN: Glad
you asked, Martin.
Well, there's good news
and then there's bad news.
MARTIN OMANDER: Uh-oh.
Well, I'm an optimist.
What's the good news, Wes?
WESLEY CHUN: Well,
Cloud Datastore
became its own product in 2013.
But the following
year, Google acquired
Firebase for its amazing
realtime database.
Both teams then worked
together and launched
the next-generation scalable
NoSQL database in 2017.
To show that Datastore
joined forces with Firebase,
the product was rebranded
as Cloud Firestore.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Oh, yeah, and you
told me to wait until
this video to learn more.
So here we are.
You also mentioned
that Firestore
is fully compatible
with Datastore,
and that all Datastore
databases will be converted
to Firestore under the covers.
Is that right?
WESLEY CHUN: Yeah, Martin.
Once converted, they
will be operating
in Datastore Compatibility Mode,
or Firestore in Datastore mode,
for short.
This mode, however,
does not give you access
to Firestore's native
features, only Datastore's.
In order to access
all of Firestore,
you need to be running
in Firestore Native mode.
Similarly, when prompted to
create a new NoSQL Datastore,
you get to choose between
Firestore in Datastore mode
or Firestore in Native mode.
Check out the chart
in the docs to see
the differences between them.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, I see.
So all users need to do
is switch from Firestore
in Datastore mode to Native
mode, and they're good, right?
But I think I better ask now.
What's the bad
news you mentioned?
WESLEY CHUN: Yeah.
I think you know what
I'm going to say.
You can't switch between
Datastore and Native Firestore
modes.
Once the mode is set and data
is stored, the mode is locked.
Also, to compound matters,
Datastore and Firestore
are mutually exclusive
in GCP projects,
meaning that once
the mode is locked,
not only can you not change it.
But in order to
use the other mode,
you need to actually
create a brand new project.
MARTIN OMANDER: So
what you're saying
is if I've got
data in Datastore,
even if I migrate to the Cloud
NDB or Cloud Datastore client
libraries, I'm not able to use
Cloud Firestore in Native mode
unless I create a new
project with a new app,
select Firestore in Native
mode in that new project,
dump the Datastore data
out of my current project,
and load it into Firestore
in the new project?
WESLEY CHUN: Yep, you got it.
And now you know why
this is even more
optional than moving from
Cloud NDB to Cloud Datastore.
At least with that
migration, you
don't have to create
a brand new project.
But this one does require that.
And it doesn't matter if it's
App Engine app, Cloud Run,
or even a non-Cloud
app using Datastore.
You have to have a new project.
So once again, you really
need to have a good reason
to make this migration.
And if accessing those Firebase
features is compelling enough,
you got to do what
you got to do, right?
MARTIN OMANDER:
Yeah, that's right.
Well, I do want to take
advantage of Firestore's
native features, and I'm
willing to create a new project
to make it happen.
How do I get started?
WESLEY CHUN: Well,
the first thing
is you must recognize that there
are two pieces to this puzzle.
First, your data
must be transferred
from Datastore in
your current project
to Firestore in the new project.
That's part one.
Secondly, it probably
goes without saying
that you need an app in that new
project that uses the Firestore
client library.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK, I got it.
But before we do
that, I remember from,
was it, module 3 that the
Cloud Datastore client
library can be used by both App
Engine and non-App Engine apps.
Is that true for Cloud
Firestore, as well?
WESLEY CHUN: Yeah,
definitely Martin.
While we're going to demo
migrating an App Engine
app to Cloud Firestore, it
could be any app, really.
The only real
requirement is that you
have to have a new project.
And since you
mentioned module 3,
that's where we created
our Cloud Datastore app.
So we're going to migrate
that one to Cloud Firestore.
Specifically the Python 3
version, as Python 2 apps
are more likely to be
using Cloud NDB instead.
So if you did the
codelab, use your code,
or grab ours from
the module 3b folder
by either cloning the repo
or downloading the zip file.
Pause here if you need to.
But once you're ready, let's
go to the computer now.
OK, before we start, we
need another Cloud project
for Firestore.
So make a new one in
the Cloud Console,
or reuse an existing one where
neither Datastore nor Firestore
are used.
Grab that project's ID--
not the project name,
nor number, the ID.
Then enable the
Cloud Firestore API.
If you prefer the command line,
use gcloud projects create,
then change to that new
project with gcloud config set,
and finally, turn on Firestore
with gcloud services enable.
Of course, you'll be asked
to enable billing, as well.
Since we always suggest you
start with working code,
deploy the module
3 Python 3 app,
whether you're
using yours or ours.
But do this from
your old project,
the one using Datastore.
Use gcloud config list to
see your current project,
and use gcloud config
set, if necessary.
Once you're on your
Datastore project,
run gcloud app deploy
and confirm the app works
like before.
Now switch to your new project
with gcloud config set project
one more time, as we'll be here
the rest of this migration,
starting with the
configuration files.
The only config
you need to change
is to switch from Cloud
Datastore, or Cloud NDB
if you're using that,
to Cloud Firestore.
There should be a one-line
swap in requirements.txt.
All other changes
are in main.py.
Replace the Cloud Datastore
client library imports
and API client instantiation at
the top with the same for Cloud
Firestore.
Groups of like
entities in Datastore
are identified with
a common parent key.
Entities in Datastore
are referred
to as documents in Firestore.
Entities are of a certain
kind in Datastore,
while Firestore documents
are grouped as collections.
When storing a new
visit in Datastore,
a new entity is created
with the visit parent key.
Likewise on the
Firestore side, we
set our collection to the same
name as a Datastore parent key.
The Datastore entity gets
its data key-value pairs
in the same way that a
Firestore document does,
but the latter gets
added to the collection
immediately, while the
Datastore entity has
to be written explicitly.
Next are the Datastore
queries where
you query for visit entity
kinds, the desired ordering,
then fetch and return.
For Firestore, query
the visit collection,
specify the ordering,
fetch and convert
to Python-friendly
dictionaries, then
return as a
memory-friendly iterable.
Believe it or not,
that wraps the changes
necessary to switch from Cloud
Datastore to Cloud Firestore.
The real work is in having
to create a new project.
So what do you think of
that migration, Martin?
MARTIN OMANDER: That migration
wasn't too bad at all.
But earlier, you said any
app can use Cloud Firestore.
If I'm willing to create a new
project to access Firestore
and take the effort to
migrate my data over,
does this mean I can rewrite
my Python 2 Datastore
app as a Node.js Firestore app?
WESLEY CHUN: Absolutely, Martin.
Your Datastore app could
be App Engine, Cloud Run,
or even non-Cloud.
It's not like the
old App Engine days,
where if you're using Datastore,
it had to be an App Engine app.
That's certainly not
the case anymore.
So the same applies
to your new project,
meaning you can
have any app using
Firestore as its database.
So if your company is doing
more work in Node.js today,
there's nothing wrong with
rebuilding or refactoring
as a Node 16 Cloud Run app for
your new Firestore project.
That's what we mean by
App Engine, and really
all of Google Cloud
as a whole, being
more open than ever
before, for both your data
and for your apps.
MARTIN OMANDER: Hm.
Well, that's really interesting.
I've been thinking
about doing exactly
that, as my team is doing
more with Node.js these days.
Anyway, now that I know how to
migrate my app to Firestore,
what about migrating my data?
WESLEY CHUN: Definitely, Martin.
We're going to tackle
that in module 10.
While you're awaiting for
the data migration sequel,
here are some additional
resources to consider.
Earlier, we linked you to a
chart differentiating Datastore
and Firestore Native modes.
Above that chart is our
guidance on which of those modes
to choose for your apps, so
check that page in the docs
and just look over all
of the Firestore docs,
anyway, to become familiar with
your brand new NoSQL database.
Also, check out this other
video from one of our colleagues
that dives deeper into the
migration and the differences
between Datastore and Firestore.
MARTIN OMANDER: Cool.
I'll check those out.
Now are there other
migrations I should
consider for my App Engine app?
WESLEY CHUN: Well, first,
you can see from this list,
we've already migrated
from our old App Engine
Datastore and NDB to Cloud
NDB, Cloud Datastore, and now
Cloud Firestore.
However, if you're
on Cloud NDB, you
can migrate directly
to Cloud Firestore.
There's no need to migrate
first to Cloud Datastore
and then go from
Datastore to Firestore.
just combine module
3 with this module 6.
As far as other
migrations go, if you're
thinking about containerizing
your App Engine
apps to run on Cloud Run, go
and check out modules 4 and 5.
Modules 7, 8, and
9 help you learn
about how to migrate from
App Engine Task Queue
to Cloud Tasks.
Finally, if you've got a small
app that's just one function,
or a big app that
you want to break up
into multiple
microservices, consider
migrating to Cloud Functions.
You'll find that in module 11.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah.
Thanks for the pointers.
There are so many
ways to upgrade.
WESLEY CHUN: Well,
that's definitely true.
We want to give our
users lots of options.
And thank you,
viewers, for staying
with us on these journeys
modernizing your serverless
apps.
This is Wesley from Google Cloud
on behalf of Martin and Porter,
hoping you'll join us soon at
the next "Migration Station"
or on a different
"Serverless Expedition" soon.
Please like and subscribe to
see more content like this.
And until next
time, happy travels.
[MUSIC PLAYING]